[Music]
foreign
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studio
this is the Ramsay show it's where
America is hanging out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money I'm Ken Coleman joined by George
Campbell the phone number to jump in is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's get right to the
phones Ryan is joining us in Raleigh
North Carolina Ryan how can we help
okay
um first off how are you doing well I'm
having the time of my life I'm with
George Campbell for a better part of my
afternoon it doesn't get much better
than that
I'm sure it doesn't
um he said that in sarcasm he's hoping
for some some career advice okay I've
been working the debt snowball I've been
doing everything and it's honestly it's
just been a very long hard slog of uh of
a track yeah I think it's been going on
about 10 years since I started my
journey oh my okay
uh and I'm just I'm I'm wore out I've
been looking at my life trying to figure
out where where I've gone wrong what
I've done and I realized I've just not
had a decent career I mean and a decent
job even where it pays enough I've never
made over 40 000 a year okay well let me
just start by saying those days are over
starting today
because you've got to actually believe
and then beyond belief you have to then
act on that belief I believe I can make
way more than forty thousand and now I'm
going to do what it takes to do that are
you in that mental place do you truly
believe you can make more than forty
thousand dollars a year
I know I'm worth more than 40 000. I
know you're worth more there is no value
we can put on a human being I'm saying
do you believe that you can make really
really good money yes or no
yes all right everybody can yeah all
right good so what specifically do you
need my help with because you're you're
presenting as though you're going I've
never done it I believe I can do it but
I don't know where to go from here is
that what we're dealing with or we have
a good idea of the destination but not
sure how to climb it what what's your
best description of where you sit today
um basically exactly what you said I I
just I don't know where to go I don't
know how to find anything my work
background is basically
um very eclectic all right forget about
that you're telling me from TV to
working in retail okay do you know what
you want to do
honestly I I think you do I really enjoy
repairing arcade games I I mean I mean
the coin slot arcade games that you you
and I probably played in the 90s yeah
and 80s yeah but okay so let's let's go
deeper
let's forget the specifics of what you
like to repair what do you enjoy about
that idea of repairing old machines
especially it's just it's getting
things working again that weren't
working either right or not good all
right I mean so what is something else
that you enjoy working on
give me something else whether you've
done it or not for a paycheck I don't
care what would you look forward to
tomorrow if I set up an eight hour day
and I'm not going to let you say old
arcade and video games we've already
thrown that out one give me some throw
that one out give me something else you
would enjoy doing all day tomorrow if I
said here are the tools you've got the
know-how fix this all day long what
would you be fixing
um
you've already thought of it you've
already thought of it so say it
um cars sometimes
um I have an electric truck I've been
working on for a little bit so let's
just say cars and machines if you could
do that all day long tomorrow and do it
in an environment where you were
appreciated and you were rewarded would
you jump into that or would you think
twice about it jump or think twice what
would you do
honestly I'd be on the fence because
I've I've
why would you be on the phone I've had
people I've had I've had things start
off as at work valued and appreciated
and then all of a sudden yeah but you
change that but you changed the question
on me so Ryan you're an overthinker
aren't you yeah big time the whole
audience can hear it and I'm not
knocking you I'm trying to wake you up
from it I gave you a question I'm gonna
ask it again and you're not allowed to
think your way through the question and
change anything answer it as I ask it
if I gave you a gig tomorrow or you're
making really good money
fixing cars or some other type of
machine and you were in an environment
where you were valued and rewarded for
your work would you jump to it or would
you think twice about it
probably count you would jump but she
still said probably
now George you're you're you are one of
my closest work friends we've known each
other a long time and I'm bringing you
into this
for a reason you're a neurotic
overthinker as well one thousand percent
and I don't say that in a negative way
because we both are
George you've heard this entire
conversation he's identified what it is
he wants to do but he's still
overthinking everything is honestly this
probably that what would you say to him
well there's some analysis paralysis
happening here and not to make it an
arcade analogy but you're like a pinball
just flying around on the machine going
well I hope something sticks and someone
appreciates me and I remember bouncing
around like that but the question you
have to ask underneath everything you're
doing is what is it about this task this
skill that gives me life and was it what
it is that drains me that I never want
to do again and as you start drilling
down which is exactly what Ken's
material does his book from paycheck to
purpose which is what we'll send you at
the end of this is get clear career
assessment it helps you figure out the
route because once you figure out the
route you can go do a bunch of things
and actually really enjoy it and make
great money but right now we're just
stuck on that fence and so we've got to
make a decision to go I'm gonna dive
into this for six months I'm gonna
explore being a mechanic and see if I
love that because you can make great
money being a mechanic I don't know the
career potential of you know fixing
arcade games it may be a hobby there may
be a million dollar business yeah but
we've got to explore it and do some
homework so Ryan today's the day you
stop thinking and you know what you have
had a checkered past some of it your
fault some of it not your fault it
doesn't matter you're good at fixing
machines yes or no
yes you like fixing machines yes or no
yes you can make more than forty
thousand dollars a year fixing machines
yes or no
yeah all right so here's the deal pick a
direction it's not going to lock you in
for the rest of your life let's go get
qualified what qualifications must I
have
to fix cars or fix other types of
machines hey look into fixing uh uh heat
and air
hey it's all the same basic idea whether
it's a carburetor or the inside of an
HVAC system you want to talk about doing
work that matters go fix somebody's heat
and air unit in extreme weather you're
the most valuable person in our life and
that's part of what's going on with you
Ryan you don't see the value
to who you are and what you're doing for
people when you fix a machine but the
world moves on people like you Ryan so
let's look at all the different machines
and things that I could fix what do they
pay what's the upward Mobility look like
and then what does it need to be
qualified go after that and then you're
on your way hang on this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today okay
and set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague
George Campbell that's camel with a K
thanks we are here for you triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five and I gotta mention if you're a new
listener and George as you know we're
getting new people in
um every day that we put the shot it's
very exciting and if you want to dive
deeper into this Ramsey system we call
the baby steps go to ramseysolutions.com
click on get started simple click and
we're going to help you assess where you
are in your financial Journey as it
relates to what we talk about here on
this program and then we'll get you the
resources you need to move forward
ramseysolutions.com click on get started
now speaking of getting started
I am just now getting started with
understanding the new vernacular that's
coming out of my kid's mouth that's true
I've got three teenagers so it's capped
this and there's all these kind of new
terms all the time it's mid oh yeah
that's a new one have you heard this one
I've heard this is their way of saying
it's average it's oh that's so mid and I
I have no idea so I'm I'm trying goal
post moves every day it moves every day
I'm a father of three teens I'm
hopelessly uh unable to stay up with the
terms there's no point of understanding
it because you can't use it because then
they make fun of you and say no you
don't get to say that yeah and then I
use it on the show and then you make fun
of me either I win either way you're not
gonna but one of the terms I am familiar
with is Yolo which apparently and I'm
stepping out on a real scary precarious
edge here I think it means you only live
once is that right Jordan ding ding ding
all right and so uh why does this matter
this term so I like to keep you young by
showing you new videos that I find on
Tick Tock yeah and you're helping me
there's some actually as much as you
know people like to hate on Tick Tock
there's some really creative uh funny
people out there making some great
content and one guy I follow Matt
bouchelle uh made one that he walks
through the streets of New York with
General observations this one is about
checking your bank account on Monday and
YOLO is the theme here so I want you to
see this for the first time all right
we'll get your reaction
every Monday I play my least favorite
game show it's called should I check my
bank account or should I just keep being
happy because no one wins it's kind of
scary I don't think 824 could make a
scarier movie than the moment when you
officially log in and see that credit
card number you're like like how much
have I racked up on this thing and the
second you see it it's always a little
too high so you're like well I will be
composing a strongly worded email to the
bank to let them know that uh fraud has
been committed on my account and then
you click it because all the pending
stuff now that it's Monday it's gone
through to like pend it I guess is the
word and then you look at it like hey
let's see what happened here let's see
if I can find what happened like well
did go get dinner there and then uh yeah
I did go get drinks at that bar with
every and then yeah we did take that
Uber across town Kevin did Vemma me ten
dollars for the 70 Uber so that's pretty
much fine and then uh yeah we did go to
that bar we did go to that bar you're
like okay okay that's fine then you see
one thing you're like a boogie company
fifty dollars a boogie company and
you're like I got it I found the fraud
and then you remember in the Uber you
bought like a weird t-shirt from an
Instagram ad from a brand you've never
heard it like oh nope they got me this
time they got me it's so sad there's
nothing you can do you just have to
admit defeat close out of the bank app
go into Google and just type in like how
to actually cook dinner
okay so I get the Yola reference yes
yeah so he's walking through the average
kind of millennial gen Z's lifestyle and
they're going there's got to be fraud in
here somewhere I don't I didn't spend
all this money right and it turns out it
was all him at the end of the day so
he's a funny Creator and really Taps
into what people are feeling these days
which is I'm broke I have almost no
money in the bank but I want the
happiness on this side I want the YOLO I
want to go out with my friends I want to
enjoy my life and they feel like they
can't have both
and we know that's not true but we also
know it takes sacrifice and you can't go
out every weekend to all four bars and
go Uber all around town and buy anything
you want from Instagram and still have
money in the bank I'm gonna come up with
a new uh a new thing for this what is it
i2i oh no the letter I I know this I
number two and then I injury to insult
is what this practice is I'm gonna get
in I know I'm broke but I don't know how
I'm broke I know I'm broke but I've got
to go back and do this awful scavenger
hunt in my bank account and just keep
getting an injury and the insult that's
an old phrase it's terrible I hope
Jensen fix that one up again they're not
going to who came up with that one oh
this 47 year old guy Ken Coleman yeah
this old Boomer is trying to wear a
hoodie to look cool next to George oh
that's good no but you understand what
I'm saying that's horrible oh the key is
you know exactly we know exactly what
we're doing to ourselves but we don't
want to feel any pain pain which by pain
I mean getting on a budget being
intentional saying no to friends having
the boundaries to say hey man I'm trying
to get out of debt I want to have more
than 40 dollars in my bank account at
any given moment which means I'm going
to be side hustling driving for Uber
instead of getting into an Uber yeah and
that's a very different mentality and
that's what I had to do when I was
getting out of debt I drove for Uber and
Lyft so I was downtown Nashville on the
weekends Ken but I was doing it because
I was trying to make an extra 40 50 60
70 that night to pay off debt here's one
more old man uh idea here on this if
you're spending you're young you're out
hanging out with everybody every night
that food and drink it better be really
good because you are fortunate you are
kind of forfeiting your future
um
uh you were delaying real Independence
real Financial Freedom all because you
want to go have you know not even that
good of an appetizer well they go well
can I cook this at home and I get this
feedback Ken well cooking at home is
it's even more expensive than eating out
goodness gracious because here's what
they do they go willy-nilly to the
grocery store get all this stuff they
can make one meal out of it throw the
rest away and then complain that 90 on
groceries is more expensive than forty
dollars on eating out yeah that makes no
sense you don't you ought to do will be
a fun video for you on Tick Tock and
YouTube is take some young gen's ears
that are single and working and take
them to Costco oh and literally shop for
you it would be my heart's Delight I
know you would love that wouldn't you
yes be good video like literally go okay
you know look I'm literally gonna shop
for you for a month cut of food you like
and then you go on there and you're
gonna look this will last they tell me
their budget yes and we shop within that
budget yeah they think you're gonna work
miracles
man this is a great idea if any gen's
ears are open to hanging out with me and
going to Costco yeah let me know yeah at
George Campbell maybe Ken will tag along
we'll get some free samples yeah I tell
you what and I could just be the old guy
who eats the samples and comments on the
samples that's a good pot sticker right
there I'll tell you that right now I
don't know why I'm doing that the
content America needs yeah let's go to
Ryan in San Jose California Ryan how can
we help
hey guys Jose California Ryan how can we
help
hey guys yeah thanks for taking my call
uh so I've been following your guys
principles uh for a little while now uh
my family kind of uh taught me some of
the same things when I was growing up
and um my question today is to kind of
get an idea if there's any intentional
things that we should be doing in terms
of saving for our next home um and our
circumstance right now is that we have
about 305 000 income a year
our home is worth about 520
we have 170 000 in debt towards that and
have a plan in place to pay that off
around February of this next year
awesome
um
we have about 40 000 Company stock and a
36 000 emergency fund as we sit today so
we're trying to think yeah you know once
we have the house paid off next February
is there anything we should be doing
other than just saving the money and
putting it and letting it sit in our
savings account as we anticipate that
new house and three to four years out
okay so you're going to pay this house
off next February but then it's going to
be another three years until you move
that's correct and so you'll be in what
we call baby step seven you'll have no
debt whatsoever and a fully funded
emergency fund and you're still
investing correct correct love it well
with a three year time Horizon I'm
probably just gonna Park that in a high
yield savings account and stack up that
cash quick if you were talking five plus
years I would say we can invest that in
some mutual funds index funds and allow
that money to grow but with three years
it's kind of a tight time Horizon where
the market could take some dips and all
of a sudden you're trying to make this
move but you're down
and so with your income you're going to
have no problem you know saving up what
150k a year for three years yeah on top
of your paid for house which will only
continue to appreciate over the next few
years
yeah that's the plan is your goal to pay
cash for the next house
yeah we'd like to pay cash
um you know and that's hopefully buy it
out right but we'll have to make those
decisions kind of depending on where we
are when the time comes man that's
awesome yeah factor in your your closing
costs and of course your moving costs
but outside of that all the equity is in
the house and you're going to be able to
roll that into the next one on top of
that huge pile of cash you guys have
what an incredible picture of what it
looks like to have peace financially man
way to go yeah seriously Ryan you are a
stud your wife heroin you guys are
amazing this is why we do the show
George
is really really bright they sound like
the camels Jordan Whitney I'm with that
they're in that club I love that all
right don't move more of your calls
coming up this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
C of chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
show continues on Ken Coleman George
Campbell joins me in studio this hour
it's a free phone call if you want to
jump in we're going to talk about your
life specifically your money your work
because I'm in here today if you're just
feeling stuck you want to get a raise
maybe you've been overlooked rejected
trying to figure out what that pivot is
anything work related we'll take those
calls as well triple eight eight two
five five two two five hey uh taxes are
confusing that's why I use a pro George
um the idea of me doing my own taxes
I don't trust it you're getting audited
man you missed a few boxes I'm sure as
you would say forget about it is that
how you say it I no one would take me
seriously I do bada bing bada boom
that's it same idea uh but if you uh if
you want to make sure that you've got
your taxes in order
um you need a pro uh big life changes
can mean big changes for your taxes that
may have happened to you this year uh
maybe you had a baby bought a house
started a business taxes may be the last
thing on your mind but I promise you
they're not the last thing on Uncle
Sam's mind
um and so uh with all those potential
Life Changes uh you're gonna need to
have a pro making sure that you get the
break you need or that you pay what
you're supposed to pay uh so how do you
keep all this straight a Ramsay trusted
po that a pro rather Ramsay trusted Pro
as George would say bada bing bada boom
a Ramsay trusted Pro will help you
they're part of our endorsed local
provider program and you can use Ramsay
smart tax if you're comfortable filling
it out online now George I feel like you
could use Ramsay smart tax and do a
great job on the other hand would get
distracted and go to jail I actually
have my tax appointment this weekend oh
you do with a pro okay I just don't mess
with it I don't want to mess with it
either so that's why you get a Ramsay
trusted Pro to help you uh walks You
Through by the way if you want to use
smart text it walks you through all the
steps to claim all the major deductions
and credit your eligible for and it's
available for only 19.95 so we got your
do-it-yourselfers the Ramsey smart tax
will do it for you for only 19.95 or if
you're like George and I and you're
scared a Ramsey trusted Pro is the way
to go here's how you get both resources
ramseysolutions.com tax that's
ramseysolutions.com
tax all right let's go to Mary who joins
us in Knoxville Tennessee Mary how can
we help
yes I have 281
000 in my savings right now and the bank
called me the CDs are at 4.25 do you
think it would be okay if I tied up some
of my money in a CD while I learn about
investing
great question Mary where did this money
come from
uh my husband recently passed away in
about 220 of it is is life insurance I'm
so sorry for your loss how long ago was
that
uh December December 26th oh my goodness
how long have you guys married
42 years wow incredible well what a
legacy to leave to uh leave you with
only the the grief of that loss versus
Financial grief as well so are you gonna
are you in a good place financially do
you have any debt
and I was I thought I'd pay that off and
that would take me down to 215
000. okay so you only have about what 65
left on the mortgage
yes okay and are you working are you
retired
I am retired I retired when he got sick
for the second time
um I do have a 403b or he did it's got
102 000 in it
okay and are you needing the income
created from this 281 that's sitting in
savings or do you have income separately
that you're living off of I I think I'm
going to be okay I've done my math and
like I'll have 4 300 a month with my
Social Security and my retirement I was
a a teacher okay and I think my budget
is just about 2 800. oh good that's good
news and so you're saying hey I don't
need this 281 000 right now I want to
park it for now I want to invest it long
term but right now I just want to park
it
right okay because I don't yeah what's
your mortgage about investing what's
your mortgage payment per month once we
pay this house off that's coming off the
list so what's that number
oh well now I didn't put that in the 28
okay it's just it's 852. okay great
awesome
so here's what I would do temporarily I
wouldn't park it in the CD only because
we don't know what the future holds and
I don't want you to get dinged with
penalties for pulling the money out of
that CD prematurely
oh oh I see what you mean so instead of
a CD which you can get the same rates
right now with a lot of high yield
savings accounts online okay and most of
those are going to be FDIC insured
and so you'll you'll uh Park that money
in a safe place you can get I'm getting
you know four percent right now in my
high yield savings account and it's
totally liquid and so if you needed the
money for anything you can pull it out
without any penalties
okay and then longer term I want you to
sit down with a smartvester pro so that
we can make this money work for you long
term do you have a financial advisor
right now
I don't but I am interviewing I used
your website and
um it sent me back like five different
Pros perfect I've interviewed my first
and I have two appointments this week oh
my goodness I'm so proud of you so
that's the long-term play because what
we can do with this money is if you
invest you know 200 000 250 000 into
good growth stock mutual funds if you
look they'll show you this the long-term
Return of the stock market has been 10
to 12 percent
and so okay I want that money to grow
for you now some years like last year it
was down 18 or 20 percent some years
it's been up 30 and so the goal is if we
don't need this money long term we can
let it sit and grow and that money can
compound which means the interest is
earned then the money you're making
interest off of that interest plus the
balance and over time that could turn
into 400 500 600 000 dollars
okay so that would be the end goal is so
that you can live the life you really
want to live do you feel like you're
missing out right now do are you
covering all your expenses and then some
I think so yes I'm doing well okay good
it's been a month oh my goodness I know
I can't even believe you're here calling
the show getting all this done just two
months later
well I just don't I just
you just went into action mode I wanted
to work for my children I I don't know
we'll be smart with it you're you're
incredible Mary the fact that you're
level-headed enough to even be looking
at all this interviewing Pros I'm just
I'm proud of you and I'm so sorry for
your loss I cannot imagine going through
what you went through
you is there any material out there for
me to read and learn more about the
absolutely funds and investing yeah we
we cover that in a lot of our books I'm
going to send you a copy of Dave's book
baby steps millionaires which walks
through his investing strategy that so
many people have used to build wealth uh
of course we've got lots of articles on
our website uh around hey here's the
four mutual fund types here's how to go
through the selection process and of
course the smartvestor pro will help you
with that as well so hang on the line
we're going to send you a copy of baby
steps Millionaires and we are wishing
you the best on this journey yeah Mary
we are sorry for your loss but you were
in great shape financially you've got
all of the uh all of the fundamentals in
place uh to to live very very
comfortably and as George has just laid
out advice for you you're gonna win
you're going to win financially in the
years to come so make that choice and
what I love about Mary George
is sometimes I think people miss this
part of the advice we give so for new
listeners new viewers
we really recommend that you interview
multiple smart Fester Pros in this case
Mary went to the website
ramseysolutions.com
she clicks on Smart Master Pro we shoot
back people that are in her area that
have already been vetted by us but we
still say
and interview them
put them on
notice that hey you are deciding who's
going to handle your money and interview
them stay in the driver this is about
connection this is about do I understand
everything not do I feel like they're
good enough to make all these decisions
for me you've got to understand the
process absolutely and the other thing
that I love is that there was life
insurance in place and we recommend
everyone have term life insurance avoid
whole life insurance altogether you want
term life insurance level term uh 10 to
12 times your annual income and you can
get a 15 20 25 you know year level term
and the great news is if something
happens God forbid you have a giant pile
of money that you can invest and you can
peel some of that off a small percentage
every year so that you can sustain
yourself financially after losing that
person's income so if you have anyone
that depends on your income get term
life insurance today our friends at
Xander that's who I have mine through
and all of our team members here have it
go check it out ramseysolutions.com you
can check out all of those resources do
you have a money question do you have a
professional a work question you have a
relationship question hey it's a free
phone call George and I are here for you
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
foreign
Coleman
joined by George camel uh always always
good to be with you George uh it is a
free phone call if you want to jump in
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five uh let's see here
let's go to Christy who's joining us in
Terre Haute Indiana you ever been there
George no I we've done a few live we did
a couple before my time yeah before your
time all right let's go to Christy
Christy how can we help
hi thanks for taking my call
my husband and I we just bought a house
back in December and it's an older 1960s
home and uh we've been getting our
electric bills now and they're quite
expensive our heating system is the
original heat but um it does a good job
it heats the house well but we're in
babysit too and my husband he's going to
be getting a um
bonus coming up I didn't know if we
could use the bonus to upgrade our
heating Source aha what's this new
furnace going to cost
it's going to cost 6 500. okay and how
much debt do you guys have
we have a hundred and fifteen thousand
what kind of debt is that
um mostly student loans there's a little
bit of credit card we have one car loan
and uh some personal loans but mostly
student loans okay and what's the
household income
and we make 145 combined wonderful
what's the electric bill running
it was eight hundred dollars wow yeah
it's and it's a total electric homes and
we we weren't expecting that at all and
I thought I had a heart attack the first
electric bill we got so what do you
think it would be with this new furnace
well the house that we lived in
previously our electric bills were less
than half and the house was twice the
size so we thought downsizing at home we
would come out ahead and we would have a
bigger shovel to pay down debt and then
once we got the electric bill it really
really took us back and we thought well
our shovel decreased a little bit and uh
as far as the utilities we're still way
ahead by downsizing at home you could
save 500 bucks a month by getting a new
furnace oh yeah probably that's what we
were thinking and we also had someone
out and they they thought maybe we could
do a wood stove and it was 5500 to put
in a wood stove so I didn't know if
that's something we should consider or
if we scrap this completely and use the
well let's play this out for a second
what would the wood stove would that
remove all of the heating the electrics
I mean it's going to drastically reduce
it even more
um I I would think we would have very
minimal electric bill
um from what the contractor told of
course he could just be upselling us you
know to buy a stove but for our size of
home he said we would easily heat the
house with a wood stove
yeah but what about AC because if you
get the HVAC system you get your AC as
well yeah we already have central air
this is just have you gotten a few
quotes system that we have is like in
the ceiling but some people call it
cable heat or radiant ceiling heat like
I said it's really warm heat it's just
not very energy it's not efficient yeah
have you gotten a few quotes or is this
the only guy we got three quotes on the
furnace and we got two clothes on the
wood stove okay and how much is your
husband's bonus that's coming in
it's gonna be fourteen thousand oh
wonderful and how much do you have in
the bank right now
um and our savings are checking just
combined
um
trying to
customers we've got it can be a round
number just estimate
probably five thousand okay we've got
we've got some money in our that's
mostly in our savings
so we'll have 19k in liquid cash once
this bonus comes in roughly right yeah
and so if we spend 6500 on the furnace
that still leaves us with 12 or 13 to
start throwing at our smallest debt and
hopefully that saves us a lot of money
so if this is a burning issue no pun
intended
um go ahead and get the furnace done
it's not urgent it's not broken it's
just inefficient so there's not there's
not a true need I wouldn't call it an
emergency
um okay but if this has just been a real
pain point for you guys and it's it's a
hurdle for you to continue to this debt
payoff journey and you could have an
extra six grand in your life it should
Roi within the year at that point if you
say 500 bucks a month for 12 months
that's six grand that's what the furnace
costs
that's what we were thinking we've had a
mild winter here in Indiana so I'm
afraid if we'd have a typical winter you
know what what will our electric bill be
next winter sort of thing yeah
and uh beyond that I would just set up a
little a sinking fun line item in your
budget for home repair renovation
maintenance type stuff so that you have
a little pile of cash that's growing
over the course of the year to cover
things like this obviously this is a big
uh big adjustment here but well thank
you so much for the call Chris I mean
look that's that that's a that's one of
those things where I'm sitting there I'm
back and forth on that one because if
you had a mile was like how could we
heat that place without running the uh
the crazy uh whatever she called that
heat coming out of the ceiling I've
never even heard that before it's
fantastic well 1960s homes it was you
know right yeah built them different
back then Ken you remember thank you
remember thank you yes indeed all right
let's go to Ottawa Canada Alex is on the
line Alex how can we help
hello Hello Alex
hi
um so I just had a quick uh question
um I'm thinking of looking into buying a
new car I know the car market right now
isn't good
um and I just want to make sure I'm not
making a sort of dumb decision what do
you want to buy and how much does it
cost
um so I'm gonna look at the numbers
right now I'm debating maybe Mercedes or
should I go smaller and go towards like
a Honda it's a little better but
somewhere in the range of like
15 to 20 000.
15 to 20.
yeah okay and you're paying cash
uh yes it will be fully in cash okay
what's your financial picture look like
what's your income do you have any debt
um so I've been following because I'm 22
right now I've been following the Randy
plan I guess since I was 16. so I have
zero debts whatsoever
um I paid off my college currently I
have about
uh 30 000 in the bank
um I have about maybe another 15 in
investments in mutual funds
um and a little bit more in retirement
um like maybe like like two three
thousand retirements way to go and
what's your income
80 000 a year wonderful and you're
driving something right now correct
I'm driving yeah it's been a while but
I'm driving a 2006 Honda so I've been
driving crap just like uh Hey friends
you said you've been there man been
there okay so we're gonna sell that
thing and get this new car or used new
to you
yeah so it'd be kind of new so would it
be dumb of meat if I were to go for a
Mercedes instead of going for the simple
Honda it's not dumb here's where you're
gonna run into Mercedes uh I just
actually saw this I I follow one of
these car dealership guys who gives you
the industry Insider scoop Mercedes is
holding its value and people are paying
top dollar so you're gonna have a hard
time finding a deal which means you're
going to get an older Mercedes which is
fine but you've got to be prepared to
for a higher cost of ownership that
thing may be in the shop it may be some
expensive repairs versus the Honda yeah
I I drive a Mercedes so I'm going to
tell you right now your oil change do
your homework do your homework on all
this stuff well it's an oil change cost
on the model you're looking at could
take premium gas versus it absolutely
needs to be premium gas uh and so you
start running those numbers and then you
know then you can kind of play off of
George's ratios here on on what you
should but I mean you've got the cash
yeah you're in a great place Finance
you're not doing anything dumb either
way I just want you to be prepared for
what's ahead you you could get a newer
Honda or you can get the older Mercedes
the Honda is going to have a lower cost
of ownership over you know the next few
years the Mercedes you're going to need
a bigger line item in the budget for car
maintenance and repairs that's all
nothing wrong with that yeah that's
right and you're in a spot to do it so
don't feel bad you've earned the right
man you're 22 you've crushed it you've
been following this stuff since you were
16 and it's those people can have the
hardest time parting with the money
that's right now I wanna I want our
audience to know we got new people all
the time so you went from driving a
Honda an 0-9 another Civic it had 170
000 miles I bought it for six thousand
dollars on it for six you saved up and
you bought a Tesla yes a used 2013 test
I used 2013. now and that was only after
we paid off the house so that was the
treat to myself I don't need to explain
anything you're very responsible so my
question is expenses weigh less
way less because of the uh no gas
nothing can go wrong in that thing boy I
hope unless the battery dies and I'm in
like 20 grand oh I'm gonna throw up 20
grand for a bet I think that's what they
cost Ken I don't know boy I hope you got
an emergency fund for that George I do a
lot of prayer in that car I don't know
hey always fun to be with you thank you
for being with me this hour I want to
thank James and the crew behind the
glass for keeping us on the air mostly I
want to thank you America this is your
show this this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey it's Ken if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsay wedding go
to ramseysolutions.com today to sign up
for our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
fly from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the pots
Moving and Storage Studio this is the
Ramsey Show we're going to talk about
your life specifically your money your
work and your relationships I'm Ken
Coleman George Campbell joins me this
hour we're here for you the phone number
to jump in is triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
George you warmed up I'm caffeinated and
I'm a little bit irritated so it could
be an interesting show I like where this
is heading let's go to Eden and
Louisville Kentucky Eden how can we help
hello um I was just wondering um so we
are currently on baby step number two
um we have about
maybe 12 to 14 000 in debt uh with like
car loans and stuff
um but we have been
um putting money towards our IRA and
401K uh for about a year now uh before
we you know started with the baby steps
and I was just wondering uh we're
currently putting uh three percent in
401k and three percent in IRA and uh
this employer is matching the three
percent
basically I'm wondering should we stop
doing that
um you know just start putting it all
towards baby step number two or um you
know it's just
I think it's like 60 bucks every
paycheck so it's not a whole lot
um I don't know if we should just
continue doing that or
yeah great question well part of the
plan is gazelle intensity and baby step
two and that means every extra dollar
that's going anywhere else is now
reallocated towards that debt and this
is a hard one emotionally for a lot of
people to Grapple with going well I'm
getting the free money from the employer
why wouldn't I continue to do this you
guys talk about the power of compound
interest but but we found the shortest
path to wealth is focus intensity and
when you allocate those dollars even if
it's 60 bucks a paycheck you know you do
that in the 401K the IRA it's 120 bucks
of paycheck so now we're talking 250
bucks a month round numbers
and now we multiply that out we go okay
well that's wow that's a few thousand
dollars that could help us become debt
free even faster and then once we get
back to investing we're no longer doing
these three percent three we're doing 15
and so you're gonna make up for that
lost time and you're going to retire a
millionaire if you just follow the plan
uh but again it's a hard thing
emotionally to Grapple with and I don't
want to you know minimize that but
that's exactly what I did it's exactly
what people who go all in on the plan do
and that's where they see the results so
how much faster would you be debt free
if you paused all investing right now
um
well we're already uh you know we're
trying to go all in on everything else I
did the math and we should be completely
debt free uh this time next year so it'd
probably cut it down
at least a quarter so what's your income
about 55 to 60 000. okay so household
income 55 to 60 and you've got about 14
000 in debt
and so you're saying it'll take 12
months to pay off fourteen thousand
already we're putting our entire tax
return towards the debt so we're going
to put a big dent in it um you know once
we get that in so here's the question
how can we speed that up you're going
all right we make sixty thousand it's
going to take us a year that's about a
thousand a month going towards debt what
if we could put 1200 towards the debt
what if we could put 1300 towards the
debt how does that speed up the process
and that's where it starts to get
exciting and that's when you start to go
okay I'm willing to pause the investing
I'm willing to take on the side hustle
because now I see a path for us to do
this in eight months instead of 12 and
now that's four more months where we're
not making payments and paying interest
four four more months closer to
investing again and building up that
emergency fund do you feel that momentum
that gets built
right yeah and so that's what I
encourage you guys to do uh so that it
you get to baby step forward even faster
and that's the goal what is the shortest
path because right now we're doing a lot
of things at once and we're not feeling
the progress on either side
okay yeah I'll figure that's probably
what I could say we're so unsurprising
Ken I wish I could tell Eden some like
magical stuff she's never heard but the
truth is it's the boring stuff we kind
of need to hear and go yeah that's right
I just need to go to the gym and work
out and not get that special lap band I
saw on TV that's supposed to make me
lose weight in my sleep yeah right yeah
it doesn't work and that's how it works
with money too yeah boy that's a really
good point I love that all right let's
go to Scott now in Fort Myers Florida
Scott how can we help
hi thank you guys for taking my call uh
just real quick I am on baby step two
I've paid off eighty six thousand eight
seventy nine in about two years and I
have 72
000 more to go so way to go man the
process we're trying it uh my question
actually is about term life insurance I
have a 16 year old son I am a single
father and I have full custody with
visitation can I put him as my depend or
my uh
my mother do it for the two years and
then switch him over so you can legally
name him beneficiary but he will not be
able to access those funds until he's a
legal adult and so that's where things
get a little hairy a little tricky and
so I it's probably easier to leave it
with the guardian or you can look at
creating a trust to where there would be
certain rules as to when he would access
that money
but the danger is you know you give an
18 year old five hundred thousand
dollars and hope that are going to be
okay and so that that's the more
worrisome part there's some other things
you can do like the uniform transfer to
miners act you can look into you can
also leave the money with the insurance
company and he just doesn't get it until
he's an adult
okay so there's nothing wrong with
leaving it he's listening to your show
with me not right now but oh awesome so
he's he's pretty pretty good about money
he's saving up for his first car so
that's fantastic well uh it's a great I
mean you you're thinking about this the
right way and if you want to talk to you
know a local lawyer about what it would
look like to set up a trust what it
would look like to who'd you say would
be the guardian
uh my mom so your mom could control the
funds yes I were to pass if I were to
pass it would be his mom but okay would
be the legal guardian yeah yeah got it
well I definitely cross those t's and
and Dot those eyes and make sure that
the way that flows is the right way at
least in the next few years you can
always change it uh later on and go all
right he's an adult now things are
different
but looks like you raised a great kid
man yeah thanks for the question well
you got a single parents man they've got
a lot going on and you know a lot of
single moms of course get the praise
that they deserve we want to honor them
all the time but then we got a single
dad here who's you know going about this
the right way and making sure his
family's taken care of you can we can
help a kid figure this stuff out early
on uh it's a game changer because
they're going to get bombarded with a
whole different set of messages by
culture yeah well what's the hottest new
trend for young people right now well we
were just looking at this Ken there's a
Twitter account called coin Fashions and
it's all the crypto people confessing
all of the terrible things that have
happened and what we're seeing is a lot
of young people who made a lot of money
very quickly and they're unable to
handle it and their life completely
implodes or they lose all the money
because they were a little greedy and
they had a hundred thousand even 800 000
one of these kids had at 20 years old
lost it all on a few trades and his life
is ruined and they go into deep anxiety
and depression and so the truth is no 18
year old 20 year old old should be
dealing with a scenario where they're
just handed a million dollars and told
be wise they're just not ready for that
yeah emotionally or financially no so
that's why I kept thinking of when I
when I heard the story of him going all
right he's going to be left a lot of
money at 18 and I think of the prodigal
son in the Bible and you go
please don't make any bad decisions here
yeah so you gotta live a little and
learn some things but for some reason
he's a great kid there's a reason why so
many lottery winners go broke it's just
such an unbelievable change if you're
not prepared for it you don't have a
construct for it that's why I can do
some damage get rich slow plan you tend
to keep it that way yeah I like that get
rich slow well that's not going to be
very popular no no one else it does work
all right don't move more Ramsay show
coming up right around the corner
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by my colleague George
Campbell and we are excited that you are
here uh George you know it is a fact of
life
that sequels just don't do well I don't
know if you have a strong opinion on
sequence I do because I tried to watch
Space Jam 2. yeah couldn't get through
it don't waste your time folks there it
is uh and you know sequels just did kind
of get a bad rap uh all you Macaulay
Culkin less home alone I'm looking at
you Chandler Ross Joey Rachel Monica
just stay in the 90s where you belong
some one wrote that I'm going to take
issue with that I I'd love to see a
Revival of friends where are they now
where do they hang out this time they
did The Reunion yeah I missed it wasn't
much of a reunion that was more of a
conversation yeah well what this means
is is that the wildly popular product
question for humans
uh friends second edition by Dr John
deloney these are conversation starters
very very popular and you demanded more
uh so here's one George what's a common
phrase or saying that you have no idea
what it means
oh
yeah that's a good question I mean you
hear the old time he's saying like one
Fell Swoop or you know the bird in the
bush is worth two in the hand that's why
I have no clue with that when people say
that you don't know what a bird in the
bush is worth two in the hand no idea
what that means it's interesting do you
you said it like I know exactly what it
means I think I do but I started to go
I've never even thought of yourself so a
bird in the hand is actually worth two
in the bush you said it wrong so I had
to re I got it so I had to focus so what
that means is a bird in the hand I've
got this one I got the bird here that's
worth more than saying well there's two
over here in the bush I can go get those
if I want no take the opportunity you
have before oh okay that was actually a
good explanation I thought you were just
fudging your way through it no I
literally was processing because you
said it wrong you're like a bird in the
bush and I went that's not right
I was trying to throw you off the scent
of the trail I'll tell you one that I
don't know
I know what it means but I don't know
what the gander is
do you know what this phrase is what you
know what's good for the goose is good
for the gander oh couldn't tell you what
the gander is
yeah I'll look it up who invents who
gets to invent these was there a
marketing meeting back in 1928
well they talk differently back then so
anyway all that to say this is the kind
of Juicy content you can create Yeah by
getting the questions for humans yeah so
we've got the first edition and now oh
wait a second this is the question for
humans friends Edition uh do yourself
and your friends a favor pick up the
second friends also we have a second
friends Edition that people wanted more
okay maybe it would be great if I was
comprehending what I was reading George
royalty solutions.com humans
ramseysolutions.com humans what an
interesting URL that is it is slash
humans yeah oh it is rather Macabre do
you know what that word means you're
throwing me for another loop here yeah
go look that one up during the break
that's your word of the day Macabre I'll
Google it while we take this Alyssa is
in Louisville Kentucky Alyssa how can we
help
hi George hi Ken uh thanks for taking my
call you bet what's up
I have a little bit of a this or that
question
my me and my husband and um
we lost our mother-in-law at the end of
last year and
yeah so obviously that's a huge
huge storm in our life
um
now he is the sole
heir to her estate or taking care of a
lot of stuff right now and after all of
a sudden then it will help us out a lot
however we're going through the probate
process and we have in the funds coming
in from Life Insurance to pay down baby
step two completely but what we don't
know is whether or not we should sit on
it until probate is over
just in case because my mother-in-law
was not
not the best at her finances we'll just
say that and there were some hidden
things that we found after she passed
that we have paid off what we know but
even with the estate process things come
out of the woodwork and so we're a
little nervous to use that money because
there won't be much of any left over if
we do use it for our baby step too
um I guess my list or that is should we
consider the storm mode or should we go
on and just put it all on baby step two
and try to cash flow whatever expenses
may come up during probate so do you
have the money now to pay off all the
debt are you saying you will once
probate's over
um no we have it now because life
insurance is not part of her estate
technically okay so what is what is the
worry let's walk this out let's say you
pay off all your debt tomorrow and now
you're on baby step three do you have
enough to fully fund that or are you
that is that going to take a few months
it will take a few months we're
inheriting her house and so we won't
have a house payment which is another
huge blessing which will increase our
cash flow for baby step three
but
um you know we we don't have like a
super huge income and I we just don't
know what might be coming as far you
won't be personally liable for any of
this the estate will have to eat that
and so you're not gonna get on the other
end and owe money
the detail on that is that her estate
also goes also all of it to her son and
if we're living in the house and we're
using it and then The Stumbling comes
against the estate and we'd have to give
it the house if there's a lien against
the estate
if a creditor comes up during probate
and they have a claim to the estate then
we would have to sell the house in order
to liquidate the funds to pay the
Creditor if you see what I'm saying yeah
so it kind of puts us in a pickle so how
how long is this probate process going
to take
in Kentucky excuse me the creditors have
six months from the date of the grant of
probate to come forward with their
claims and his aunt my husband Vance is
the executor
it'll be about August when that's over
when we know what all the debts will be
I still think you're going to be in a
better place financially if we knock out
all the debt today we have no payments
and we begin saving up that emergency
fund
that would still put you in a better
spot until August versus just hanging on
to the debt not sure how much debt do
you have and how much money is in the
bank
um so we're also counting on tax refund
and stuff that's probably all going to
come in this month because all that's
just in process um we'll have
we have about 21 000 in debt and it'll
be just about that much maybe 22 or 23
000 that we will be receiving okay we
already have the life insurance we're
waiting on a couple other things but
they're they're winning what's your
household income
um 55 to 60. gross okay
I think it'd be a great goal to pay off
that debt and have a fully funded
emergency fund by August
I would love that and that way you are
sleeping well at night you've got money
in the bank and we'll figure out what
happens when that time comes but I don't
want you to have this in limbo freaking
out about it until then while the you're
still making payments on this
I want you to make progress until that
time comes and hopefully it's all clean
there's no liens no creditors are coming
after you guys and uh you walk away from
this thing and you're able to just
grieve I'm so sorry for your loss though
thank you thank you
man
oh that's tough Ken it is a lot of loss
just in in today's show yeah people are
going through it
um I know you you help a lot of people
on your show and you're a great
encourager it just feels like it's a
heavy time out there you know we try to
have fun just to bring some levity to
the show but man it can just get heavy
yeah and I and I think that when life is
gets heavy like that you know what we've
got to do is certainly in financial
decisions professional decisions
personal decisions the big big decisions
just heal
heal first you know like just let's not
try to you know grit our way through it
let's let's be weak let's be vulnerable
let's get healthy and then on the other
side of the healing uh as you're healing
then your perspective changes anyway
because each day on the other side of
healing
um you're very forward thinking anyway
but I think people get into trouble uh
for instance people a lot of people been
laid off
I mean you know Disney laid off 7 000
employees last week we know from
psychology research that when you're
laid off uh from a job
even when it's expected it has the same
emotional impact as losing a loved one
wow
it's so you're not equating the two what
we're seeing the emotion is similar it's
devastating and so you know whether
again in your in your work life your
professional Journey your financial life
your relationship life
take the time to heal
get the help you need and then begin to
make the big decisions going forward
don't make big decisions in the midst of
that pain it's very very hard to uh kind
of have the best wits about you and
that's always something we want to
remind you those of you that are going
through a tough time this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com time
to save up to 45 percent off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com now to learn
more
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey show where we
talk about your life specifically your
money your work and your relationships
George Campbell is joining me I'm Ken
Coleman and I am the Ramsay personality
focused on work so if you got your work
related question that could be anything
from I don't know what I want to do I've
got to should I go to school should I
not go to school uh I want to take a
promotion I'm not getting promoted I'm
getting rejected Overlook anything work
related I got a toxic environment I'll
take those questions and to that end
we've got a work related question here
George our question of the day from
Alina uh in the official Ken Coleman
community on Facebook uh she says how do
you respond to a job offer that does not
meet your desire desired salary ah okay
it's a good question right so do you go
in
after they make their offer and do all
this big Grand negotiation
what do you think George yes or no I
don't think the way to go about it is
show back up and go
um yeah I need 50 to make this work or
I'm out okay all right so you know if
the offer was 45 yeah and you thought in
your mind it was going to be 50 or 60.
well it all depends on
how tight are you on on that paycheck so
if you need 50 to make ends meet and
they offer you 45 you're in a quandary
now I don't think there's this big Grand
negotiation anymore but what I do think
you can say in that situation is Hey
listen uh let's say you were in this
case making 50 previously or close to
you say look I can't do it for that I
want the job
but I just literally with my budget I
cannot make ends meet on that I
appreciate the opportunity but that's
the best you can do unfortunately I'm
not going to be able to stay now that's
not a negotiation that is you saying
very clearly uh based on real numbers
it's not a tactic it's I can't do it
then you'll see what they can do but
this idea of trying to negotiate is
hopefully hopefully it comes up
beforehand before the job offer there's
some discussion of compensation benefits
you can't expect that in today's world
you know there there's a big push for uh
transparency and pay and put that out
ahead of time but companies that don't
want to do that for very understandable
reasons we'll come back and they'll get
around it another way so when you're in
that conversation you got to know what's
that walk away number
if that number doesn't get to here I'm
walking away and that by the way will
come across in your communication to
where you really don't have to negotiate
and that's that's the thought George you
don't have to negotiate if you know what
your number is and what you're what
you're willing to walk from well the key
is to not put you know the HR team in a
defensive posture that's right or then
it backfires and the the the real thing
is let's do some research do you know
what the market value is based on your
skill and experience and and do you
think this company's going to be
competitive you can do that homework
ahead of time what about when they kind
of make some promises can or you know
they say well you know I know this is uh
it's not exactly what you're hoping for
but there's a big trajectory you know
within the next six months you could be
making the you know you kind of start to
get a little bit of that as well yes and
so what I would do if they start to say
that you're gonna go okay what's that
measurement look like
so what are the results
that I will need to produce and how will
we measure those results
because if they can't give you specific
answers to that now now it's one of
those they're just dragging you just
dangling a character and I share this on
the Ken Coleman show today this is
relevant paychecks just put out a new
study
80 of people who change jobs in 2021 and
2022.
regret leaving their previous shot whoa
that's a staggering number what was the
reasoning do they have no you know right
for the number one reason it wasn't the
paycheck
it was they missed their friends from
the previous job this relationship
component it's a big shift it's like
moving to a new city yeah I mean we you
know we can't undervalue relationships
in the office so I mean you and I sit
next to each other I can't imagine ever
leaving here not having Ken Coleman I
don't know what I would do I would be
distraught if I didn't see you every
morning and that perfectly coiffed beard
of yours and that meticulous part in the
side of your hair these are just the
surface things wow not to mention your
your character your character your
integrity your Sage advice you know all
the things George uh I love when
flattery turns to sarcasm real quick
that's the king Coleman I know and love
that's what we do triple eight eight two
five five two two five is the number
Rebecca's joining us in St Louis
Missouri Rebecca how can we help
hi guys thanks for taking my call
I am
so I am a 1099 employee about to start a
new position it'll be the highest income
that I've ever
earned
um and I've been divorced since 2020 and
have slowly increased my income but I am
also at the lowest point financially and
I have no money you saved up for
retirement and so
um before I get too used to this new
income I wonder if I should
um set up retirement plan as part of my
budget moving forward when I when the
money starts coming in when the income
starts coming in what's your name
it'll be 95 an hour
um but that's you know before taxes is
that is that kind of a full-time 40
hours a week
yes wonderful so we're talking almost
200 Grand
yes way to go
okay and how much debt do you have
a lot 155 just in student loans and
um then I've got another
um 55 in personal debt with a car credit
cards medical bills
Furniture loans
um with other things but I haven't
worked since the middle of December and
um I had money save up for my taxes for
last year and I've been living on that
now because I I've been between jobs and
now my savings is gone and I'm going to
have a pretty good tax bill I know and I
have a good accountant who's working
with me last year was my first year
being 10.99
um and the income was not where we had
predicted it would be at that time
um so
anyway I know I'll have a tax bill as
well and I have no more savings okay so
right now I know we're worried about
retirement we're going to get to that
but right now I want to clean up this
mess this pile I want to get the IRS off
of our back so your A1 is going to be
getting rid of this debt which with this
newfound income we can do fairly quickly
we're talking two or three years right
yes that's how I that's what I figured
too when I mapped it out yeah I was
hoping for them and if you make 200
Grand and you have 200 Grand in debt and
you can live off of 50 or 60 or 70 even
you got 100 plus to throw at the debt
and this thing's gone in two years
yeah and then think about where you're
at you have no payments in the world and
you make 200 Grand and let's say how old
are you right now
46. okay so let's say at 48 you're
completely debt free and you're maxing
out every single retirement vehicle you
can
well you still have almost yeah almost
20 years so just invest and build wealth
with no payments in the world
so you'll be able to build wealth
and you can do that through a lot of do
you have any retirement Vehicles right
now
through your employer
no nothing it'll all Beyond me okay and
um so are you going to be able to do
like a SEP IRA or solo 401k
yeah
um so I was looking at that too like I
think that would help with my tax bill
in the future like if I set some money
aside now maybe and and do put some
money into an IRA down the you know at
the end of the year or something it
might help with my taxes also but also
benefit me with during my my path
towards retirement also so I think the
best path towards retirement is getting
rid of two hundred thousand dollars
sitting around our neck with interest
that's how you're gonna be able to read
it all right because you can retire with
dignity if you just don't have any
payments and you have some income coming
in and so that's that's the goal follow
the plan all the way through
and making two hundred thousand dollars
at 48 years old two years from now
completely debt free you're going to be
able to save another 100 150 a year
there's a lot of things you can do once
you hit 50 with ketchup contributions
you have a lot of time on your side
Rebecca I know it feels like you don't
because you're 46. but there's a lot of
life ahead yes my goodness you're young
she's younger than me George make sure
we emphasize that
she's got plenty of time yeah I mean Ken
you got a lot of life to live but I hope
so goodness I hope it's not too late
folks whether you're 30 40 50 even 60
becoming debt free and maximizing your
greatest wealth building tool your
income can help you retire with dignity
when you want to instead of when you
have to he is George Campbell I'm Ken
Coleman and you're listening to the
Ramsay show don't move
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by George Campbell we're
here to take your questions about your
life your money questions but your work
questions and relationship questions we
will get those answered for you triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is the number if you like the show
please consider subscribing leaving a
review
and sharing with a friend we want to get
it out to as many people as possible
because we're bringing hope through
practical answers and a clear path
forward for you again in your work in
your money and in your relationship life
I've taken your work questions this hour
Andrew's up in Los Angeles California
Andrew how can we help
hey guys thanks for taking my call so I
am making about 2100 a month and I'm
wondering how much of my money I should
just be saving towards a bigger
emergency fund or if I should start
investing now I'm only 23 years old
cool okay what are you doing for work
uh I work at a Starbucks in Los Angeles
awesome and you're saying you've got an
emergency fund that is what size right
now uh I got about thirteen thousand
dollars in the bank okay and how many
months of expenses would you call that
uh
I'd say about like nine to ten months
wow that's plenty how cheap is your rent
uh I'm paying about 1100 a month in rent
okay so it's not nine months worth of
expenses then because your rent alone
would eat yeah sure enough oh okay okay
um but it's my job is if I do happen to
get fired or downsized I'm comfortable
enough getting a new job fairly quickly
in the service industry
okay that I'm not too worried about
having a massive massive emergency fund
so where is the the need then because
you're saying should I keep building the
emergency fund what would be the purpose
of that if you've got three to six
months already
well I'm taking classes full-time as
well and I'm wondering or for mechanical
engineering awesome and I'm wondering if
I it's worth just
or a foregoing or investing for two
three years until I have uh uh more
wiggle room a higher salary rather than
a
practically minimum wage employee and so
do you have any debt right now
no I do not my parents actually raised
me on the baby step program and I
avoided dead altogether in my life and
you're able to cash flow your coursework
for the mechanical engineering
uh yeah uh the I'm taking classes
through Starbucks and they're actually
free oh that's awesome way to go man so
why not go ahead and start investing
does Starbucks have any retirement
options 401k
I haven't looked into that too much I
don't know for certain I'd imagine they
do but I'm just wondering if it's not
more wise just to hold off until I have
like it is that or do you think my
emergency fund is sizable enough that I
can just avoid
well that's where if you're doing a
monthly budget and you take your bare
bones expenses that hey if something
went down I need to cover these expenses
take that multiply it by three to six
months and that gives you your number if
that's the I think 13 is sounds like a
reasonable number for you then I would
begin investing investing doesn't happen
once you start making a certain amount
of money it happens when you have no
debt and an emergency fund in place
because what we're really trying to do
is build that savings muscle where we
get used to 15 of our income regardless
whether it's 30 or 300 000 going into
retirement
and I would imagine Starbucks has some
decent investing options that can get
you started
uh yeah like I said I don't know for
certain but I imagine they do as well
yeah Andrew I want to Echo what George
said you're in you're in good shape if
you want to put a little bit more money
in the emergency fund go for it but but
the point is is pretty quickly uh you
need to start investing so that you just
get into this Rhythm this routine it
becomes a habit for you like brushing
your teeth you're investing every check
and that's going to serve you long term
big time as young as you are and it's
financially responsible as you've been
up to this point that's why you want to
do this you're you're fine you don't
have a lot to cover if you were to have
a true loss of work or some type of huge
emergency you don't have a lot to cover
so you're in good shape
I guess I am I I guess I really just
need that confirmation I guess that well
but you do but you don't and we're
encouraging you but you know what you
need to do George gave you the answer
you need to write these numbers out get
it out of your head and and write it
down go okay how much money would I need
uh and to have a fully funded
three-month emergency fund what would
six months look like you can go either
way anywhere in between there but
actually get that number be absolutely
certain what that number is and you're
going to be more confident and then just
do the research do the homework into
with your HR folks or the website on the
back end and say hey help me understand
this what are my investing options I'm
going to go ahead and do 15 of my income
even if it's from 15 bucks an hour 20
bucks an hour whatever it is and as you
create more income you're just going to
increase your investing along with that
and that is going to be the key to
becoming a millionaire not a magic
salary that's right and George again you
know I I talk a lot about this on the
Ken Coleman show helping people make a
big professional decision and they're
kind of you know looking for confidence
Clarity clarity
clarity
you can be confident in emergency fund
when you get clear on all of your
numbers like you told him to do then all
of a sudden you go okay
if this were to happen I'm good to go
and and that's where again confidence
replaces fear absent of information our
mind is powerful
and it will just fill in the gaps so
whether it's in financial relationship
professional decisions where I'm not
clear I can tell you I'm not confident
man that's good it's and it's a great
reminder because we talk about doing a
budget a lot around here and it's kind
of like Ugh budgets but when you think
about it through the lens of clarity and
confidence man it changes the game now
I'm doing a budget because I want to be
confident and intentional with every
single decision I'm making yeah
absolutely Gia is up in Lincoln Nebraska
gee how can we help
hi guys it's a pleasure to talk to you
so I just got a quick my husband and I
just paid off our house uh last month
whoa way to go we have Noah we have no
other debt uh my husband's 30 I'm 25. oh
my goodness wow
and my husband is going to be going back
to school in September for HVAC um just
to increase in income and find something
a little bit more stable
my question is this we kind of have a
lot of goals ahead of us of what we want
to do
actually kind of getting to enjoy a
little bit of our money because we're
still newlywed we've been married about
two years but we haven't really done a
whole lot just because we were trying to
get our house paid off and just kind of
get that behind us
so we're just trying to figure out what
we need to do we kind of have a like
kind of like a checklist of things we
want to get done and feel we need to get
done but I I know you guys always say to
focus of intentionality so I'm just
we're just trying to figure out okay how
do we focus with intentionality because
we're trying to go 18 directions I love
it well what a great problem to have so
there's three buckets that I think will
help you guys figure this out you have a
give bucket a save bucket and a spend
bucket and just create goals in each one
just for the year ahead and you can
still have a five-year goal but just say
for the next 12 months here's our goals
for giving we want to give this much
here's the organizations we want to give
to we want to have some spontaneous
generosity plan of the budget on the
spend side we want to make sure we're
enjoying this money let's plan at least
two vacations one person gets to plan
one the other gets to play on the other
we're going to upgrade the car as part
of our spending and the savings goal
we're going to start saving up uh for an
another house down the line we want to
pay cash for that makes it really clear
and it keeps you focused and excited
okay and I think our other question is
is so we you know have been following
Remedy or working with a financial
um or Finance Pro and so we were looking
at doing
um term life insurance so our question
is do we really need term life insurance
like I understand like the reason for it
and I get it but we don't have kids we
don't have any payments in the world
like if my income left or his income
left
um we would be we we both would be fine
in terms of the day-to-day and then with
my job they give me I don't know what
it's called exactly but basically they
give my husband two times my annual
salary basically the day after I die
yeah and he has a small
right now he's got a whole life plan
we're working on getting that switch so
I guess better the question is I know I
would I would still get term life in
place for both of you then get rid of
the whole life once those are in place
it's honestly so dirt cheap and it would
put you guys in such an incredible
position to be able to grieve and not
worry about how we're going to put food
on the table even though you're debt
free you still have a lot of life
expenses funerals I mean there's a lot
of stuff you'd have to consider and
having turned life in place 10 to 12
times your annual income 15 20 years
we'll put you guys in a much better spot
it's a no-brainer it really is just get
it it's so so affordable good stuff good
advice thank you so much for the call
Gia George good hour fun times uh man
goes fast when you're having fun hey to
you America thank you for listening this
is the Ramsey Show
foreign
hey George camel here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsey Show it's where we talk about
your life your money your work and your
relationships I'm Ken Coleman joined by
George Campbell this hour the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five two two five let's go to
Winchester Virginia in Shenandoah Valley
area I believe George Well Done you know
your geography well I'm a Virginian so I
hope I got that right if I know where
Winchester is Peter is on the line Peter
how can we help
hey so I'm 14 and I have 8 500 sitting
in the bank I was wondering how much I
should invest and if this is a good time
to invest wow makes the 8 500 young
Peter
well I am a Little League umpire and I
do a lot of side hustles like I run a
lemonade stand in the summer
and a hot chocolate stand in the winter
and so that's fantastic that's brilliant
how long have you been at Little League
umpire
uh this is actually my first season also
I have very generous grandparents oh
okay all right what do you make uh being
an Umpire these days at 14. I'm curious
um I get like 45 a game and how old are
the kids that are playing in this game
all right now I gotta ask you this
because I think I think people want to
hear this I want you to give me a really
strong third strike all right so it's a
third strike how do you call it
strength three very nice okay all right
he's got a style You've Got Confidence
listen I like that he didn't go
overboard because I would be like stuck
something like that I think you get
kicked out of the game no I'm the Umpire
I do the kick it out wow yeah you gotta
get George even know what baseball is
where you can call us third strike all
right nonetheless Peter back to Peter's
question you got 8 500 bucks you're
doing incredible uh you're asking about
investing and right now the best thing
to do is invest in Peter I know that
sounds like a cheap answer but the truth
is you've got a lot of life expenses
coming your way in the next six years
when you think about all right you need
to buy a car right
yeah those ain't cheap you're probably
gonna have some expenses with further
education you're thinking about going to
college one day
tips so they have some money saved away
for that but I don't know how much okay
and some living expenses so the truth is
we may have some upcoming expenses in
the next two three years that you may
want to use this money for and if it's
invested in the stock market it could be
risky because that money could go down
20 when you need it
yeah so if you want to have some fun
with this
um you could park some of it in a high
yield savings account where is it
sitting right now
okay it's making terrible interest I
should probably have it in
Dolby first of all you have a higher
grade you have a higher net worth than
most American adults so you're doing
great don't knock yourself
um you can put in a high yield savings
account which will get you four percent
and that's a great thing to do is you
keep stacking cash because what if it
comes time for you to buy a car in two
years and you go man I could buy a 12
000 car fifteen thousand dollar car
wouldn't that be cool
yeah and you've got a lot of time to
invest I mean once you are really
working and you've you've found your
career path whether that's entrepreneur
or whatever you find yourself doing
you're going to be investing way more at
that point and that's what's really
going to get the power of compound
interest going so if you don't get
started for two five years investing
you're still going to be a
multi-multi-millionaire when you retire
based on talking to you here and when
that time comes I want you to utilize
all the tax advantaged retirement
accounts that are out there which aren't
available to you right now there's
something called a custodial Roth IRA
that you can work on with your parents
to open up for you there's utmas you can
look into and of course the 529 plan so
I would put my focus on making sure
college is paid for beyond that your
future savings goals beyond that you can
look into one of those custodial
accounts how about the 14 year old Peter
yeah it's uh really fantastic he was so
down he's like well it's just sitting in
the bank making nothing love that kid
man he wants the compound interest all
right let's go to Ralph in Houston Texas
Ralph how can we help
hey we're doing kind of kind of tough to
follow up an All-Star like that um but
you're doing great
we got a we got a baby on the way oh
congratulations very happy
um right now we're making about 180 a
year I was thinking well it's probably
time for my wife to stay home we'll go
down to around 140.
we're still on baby step two we have
paid uh 38 000 in debt since 2020 but we
still owe the big guy we sold the
student loan which is about 50K
so I just want to make sure we're making
the right decision having that drop in
income where we have our last Consumer
Debt after after soon we'll only have a
mortgage
so I want to make sure we are doing the
right thing and just stopping one income
and just taking care of the kids
and just attacking the student loan on a
solo income well I I before we get into
all this I it's not a right or wrong
it's it's preference is is the narrative
what do you two prefer
well you know for the longest time I was
like well she's gonna we'll send the
baby to daycare no problem we'll do it
and then the more the number the more
I clinched the numbers the more I
thought on the stress on her I was like
you know what maybe it would be a bigger
payoff for her
so she's making about 40K
she's making about 40K yeah and so after
taxes we're talking closer to 25 28
. yeah she probably takes on like 25 26
which is probably just above the cost of
daycare at this point I think I think we
I think our SMS daycare is like 1600 a
month so it'd be a thousand dollar a
month
hit but which is actually you know that
that would burn up that would help us
burn up that student loan because we
just paid off the final credit card but
here's the thing so what you mentioned
was the stress so you were coming at
this from a husband's point of view and
you're going the stress of her worrying
about the baby being in the care of
someone else the normal stress that she
goes through with her job and all of
that combined you're like I just don't
think that's best
and and so that's not a wrong decision
that's a great decision because you go
you know I want what's best for my wife
um and and in this situation because we
can afford it listen there are a lot of
people watching and listening to this
show right now Ralph they can't afford
for the wife to go home
so you're in a really unique situation
so mathematically you're gonna be fine
yeah well even solo you make well above
the average household income this
student loan is gone in Under 12 months
regardless of what happens have you
discussed remote work though for her
even part-time remote work
uh yeah we've talked about it I listened
to some of the other shows and talk
about you know the type of freelance
stuff going on yeah yeah so she was
thinking about going full remote uh but
I think her job decided they're not
going to go for him up yeah that's when
I that's when I really contemplated you
know what I think it might be best if we
go down to one all right easy way to get
clarity go create an every dollar budget
with that scenario it's just your income
add in you know the new expenses for the
baby and you'll go oh we're gonna be
fine yeah and uh I hope he was referring
when he said other shows on the Range
Network I've been talking a lot about
the freelance economy it's as hot as it
ever has but freelancing opportunities
are all over the place just look into it
after you do that budget just see what
could she do from home you may be
surprised how it knocks out all that
debt just from what she does
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey show where we
take your money questions your work
questions your relationship questions
George Campbell is joining me I'm Ken
Coleman we are here for you this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two five five
two two five uh George you had big plans
for Valentine's Day did you budget for
it I'm not a like a night of Valentine
stresses us out it's too much we kicked
it a few days how long have you and
Whitney been married four plus years now
yeah so Stacy and I are coming up on 25
years in May and um I can't remember the
last time we actually went out on
Valentine's just because it feels like a
pro move not to go out it's a pro move
to miss the actual night it's still the
same concept the thought that counts but
I was 23 years you're a planner oh yeah
that's impressive well it's it's not
it's uh it's impressive for Stacy to put
up with me that long that's the angle I
was going to say yeah okay easy to easy
play for me very difficult play for
Stacy you know this wow you've known
well you guys are what I consider a
power couple oh is that right two
amazing people coming together to treat
something even more amazing that's very
nice thank you George you'll get there
soon it goes fast
I got 21 to go I'll never catch up
that's the problem uh well you know it's
good stuff so uh so no Valentine's Day
uh no we're gonna be on the road next
week in Indianapolis for a Building
Wealth event this week yeah so we'll do
something relaxed at home and then we'll
celebrate uh next weekend oh well next
week yeah you're pushing it first I do
the multiple reservations so that she
has options that's the real pro move and
the neurotic move let's get first I like
that all right very good Carter's gonna
join us now as we go back to the phones
he is there in Des Moines Iowa Carter
how can we help
yeah thank you for taking my call you
bet what's up
well hey my about a year and a half ago
my wife and I purchased uh well we had
our van breakdown we had a 2007 van and
and it was going to cost more to fix it
than we wanted to put into it had 230
000 miles and so we went and bought a
nice vehicle as a 2018 Chevy Equinox and
um but we ended up taking payments on it
and and it I think it was a stupid
decision we both do but but uh
um and we took a very high interest rate
um on it uh for a 72-month payment
period and and we've got about twenty
one thousand eight hundred dollars left
to pay on that 2018 Equinox and we were
getting tired of making payments of
their 450.97 a month and
um when we took it back to the dealer to
see how much we get they said 14 000 and
most other people we've talked to so we
can only get 16 000 out of the car
um so we don't we're kind of stuck in
and uh in between do we keep the car and
just
I guess enjoy our you know make the best
of our mistakes or do we try and go
about selling it at a loss it'd be a
fairly significant loss
um and but to be out of death and what
so that's what we're trying to figure
out what other debt do you have
uh we we do have uh two rental
properties which we have
um some debt on those but that's paid
for by by rental income there so but no
other personal to ask okay and what's
the household income
around this year we should be 75 to 80
000 that includes the rental income
uh that does not include the rental
income as we're not making a lot outside
at the moment okay and what's your other
car
uh well we have we have two other
vehicles we have a 2007
Dodge Grand Caravan we have a 2006
Chrysler Town and Country that we had
bought thinking we were going to sell
the Equinox but we have not been able to
sell the Equinox for so you don't need
three cars like
no we don't okay so if you sold this one
you don't need to turn around and buy
another car
you could just keep the 07 and the 06
for now you can upgrade later do you
have the cash the difference to cover
the part you're underwater on
um yes it would just be a little tight
okay well there's nothing wrong with
keeping it and just paying it off it's
not like you there's too much of your
world tied up in cars so if you want to
pay it off it sounds like you don't
really like the car that much
well it just hasn't it hasn't provided
the Practical service for for my
business as we thought and it's costing
us more than we'd like to pay for it
yeah well this is what we would
categorize under you know stupid tax if
we have to cover the difference if you
feel that pain it means we'll never do
it again and so there's nothing wrong
either way it'll speed up your debt-free
journey of course if you go ahead and
sell the car and take the hit on it or
you can just pay it off and keep it and
sell one of the other cars that you
don't need
right there's no real right or wrong
here it feels like you're leaning
towards wanting this car out of your
life though
well that that is what we're leaning
towards it's just we didn't know would
it be worth it is that a wise decision
to
um put that much money against it at a
loss
I mean if you can try to get top dollar
for it and keep searching around to
where you're less underwater on it yeah
I'd make you feel better but at the end
of the day I'm I just did some quick
napkin math here and it looks like
that's about what you're gonna get is 16
Grand Max for that thing
correct so I don't think there's going
to be a day when you go oh we got 22 for
it we're ahead unless the used car
market goes back up which I mean it's
been a wild ride man it's it's already
starting to go back up as we speak so uh
I don't I don't think you're gonna get
out from under this uh the only two
options are sell it and take the hit or
you just pay it off and keep it yeah and
Carter I understand what you're feeling
but here's the mental approach on this
it's not how much I'm gonna get for it
it's how quickly I get out
from underneath the whole thing so I'd
sell it for the 16 now get as much money
as you can pay it off and then just move
on and with that freed up payment of 450
you'll make that money back of just not
having to pay that freaking payment when
you have three cars sitting in the
driveway it's absolutely right thank you
so much for the call let's go to Austin
Texas Dave is there Dave how can we help
good morning
um give you a quick rundown I'm almost
70 years old uh retired about a year and
a half ago
um
our social security income is the only
income that we have
we come up about 500 a month short so
we're having to pull out of our you know
checking savings account to make up the
difference to pay the bills
we're trying to keep the quality of life
that we've had for the last you know 40
years which is not extravagant it's just
you know that's what it is
um my question is whether I should we
owe about five more years on our
mortgage uh just a little over fifty
thousand dollars we've got about five
hundred thousand in 401k and Ira
uh just wondering if I should pull the
money out of that and pay the house off
so that would leave you with 450 000.
in retirement yes okay yes and it would
free up the payment which was how much
on the mortgage
yeah 1200 a month ah okay so we went
from a negative 500 deficit to now have
a positive 700
well 500 because the 200 is taxes and
insurance okay but it still puts you in
a much better spot to where you're not
kind of bleeding out here and you have
no way to create extra income at this
point unless you guys go back to work
correct
yeah and I would also crunch the numbers
on hey can we survive off of this 450 if
we're you're saying you cannot touch the
450 for a while and just live off Social
Security
no I mean I I don't really want to touch
it for a while until you know until I
have to start taking the government
required you know rmds on that because
it's all traditional
yes okay
yeah I'd pay off that mortgage right now
you guys really need to get this payment
out of your life just to stay above
water and uh that 50k is not gonna it's
not gonna make enough of an impact to
destroy your retirement and destroy your
nest egg
okay but I would be working with a
financial advisor to go hey what does
this look like for the next 25 years
I can start to get a picture of that
but I'm getting rid of that house
payment man that's how I want to retire
Game Changer 1200 bucks back in my life
I'm taking it yeah
and I know
let's just work work work work work
so that we don't have to work anymore
and I you know what take a little time
off but I'd be doing something and in
this case to make a little bit of extra
money they don't have to work do
something to use stuff skills Hobbies
passions yeah I don't like this idea if
I just work for 60 years and then all of
a sudden I'm out I don't know I don't
think it's good for who we are I think
we're created to work but hey who knows
hey don't move he's George Campbell I'm
Ken Coleman and this is the Ramsey show
more calls coming up
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show where we
walk you through practical stuffs for
you to move forward in your life
specifically in your money life
in your work life in your relationship's
life I'm Ken Coleman George Campbell my
uh Ramsey personality colleague and
co-host this hour joins me Triple eight
eight two five five two two five is the
number I'm the Ramsay work personality
focusing on all things work whether
that's trying to figure out what you
want to do or if you know what you want
to do but you know how to get there if
you're dealing with toxic co-workers a
really bad boss all things work related
helping you win at work so you're
winning in life that's what I do and on
the Ken Coleman show which is part of
the Ramsey Network George we as you know
we cover current events and and in the
world of work and
the layoffs are are in the news because
all the rage it's scary stuff and the
News likes to scare us that's how they
get us to pay attention and I covered
this on the Ken Coleman show today uh
Zoom
the uh the Wonder kid of the pandemic
everybody was zooming you know I was
like hey how did Skype not get on that
they just they missed the boat man I
don't know how Skype missed it it was
like Zoom was kind of new and a couple
people started talking about it and so
Zoom blew up in a good way they were the
darling of the tech industry because
everybody was zooming Zoom this Zoom
that zoom zoom zoom and so they went
zoom zoom too many zooms so many zooms
so like I used Too Many there probably
three Mazda commercials yeah exactly
just three too many but nonetheless
announced uh that they laid off 1300
employees or 15 of its Workforce this is
from CEO Eric Juan announced last week
two staff now he went on to say
something that I've seen in the news
feels like nine out of ten times when we
see layoffs announced well we staffed up
and we overstaffed
and now the economy's changed the
Outlook has changed and we gotta let
some people go I'm really sorry it's my
fault now that's been the general
message and that's what he said as well
he took responsibility said he was going
to show accountability
by reducing his salary for the coming
fiscal year by 98 percent as well as
foregoing his 2023 corporate bonus
uh members of zoom's executive
leadership team will also jump in
and reduce their base salaries by 20 for
the year and forfeit their corporate
bonuses too his base salary last year
was 301 731 dollars just to give you
some context
um and um he offered support to those
they had to lay off by including up to
16 week salary and Health Care coverage
now I'm sure he got criticized because
that's what people do
I thought this was a classy move
um in that saying you know what I'm
going to penalize myself as well I'm
sure he's made millions of dollars
potentially in stock obviously uh but
still it's a good move but I know he was
widely lampooned by people who think
well you're the rich guy so I don't know
if they want a pound of Flesh a gallon
of his own blood what do they want
what's in that I think they really want
him to just resign and why because
they're feeling pain and therefore
everyone needs to feel pain well believe
me he's feeling pain his pain is
relative to their pain but he's feeling
pain uh it's not fun for a CEO to lay
off a bunch of people we're seeing this
across the board with big tech companies
and the truth is these are all mostly
public publicly traded companies so
they're shareholders and so at the end
of the day like it or not that's how
this runs is you got to keep the
shareholders hey happy at the end of the
day Disney did it Disney laid off 7 000
workers last week you're probably
following the story I know you're a big
Disney guy you want to talk about on the
Ken Coleman show thank you George
moments for watching Bob Iger uh former
CEO comes back and announces a
restructure lays off seven thousand
people and pointedly says in his press
release
we've got to cut costs and fix the stock
price and after hours trading the stock
price jumps
and again this is what you will be at a
large public company you will be a
number on a spreadsheet because Disney's
obviously struggling from a business
standpoint but they're not you know
they're not gonna they're not gonna have
problems keeping things open uh but I
will tell you the lesson about Disney
that I'm gonna I'm gonna take this away
from Big corporate news and I'm going to
give a quick lesson
about authenticity and winning in your
professional life
when Disney stopped being about kids
having fun
and fantasy land and all the wonderful
smiles and parents being happy because
kiddos are happy and they started
getting involved in pushing the social
agendas
when ESPN stopped talking about sports
it started getting into things outside
of sports their numbers are hurting I'm
not saying they're right or wrong for
doing it I'm simply saying the business
cases stick to who you are as a business
don't try to be cute with who you are as
a person who are you authentically uh
who are you as a business and trying to
get cool trying to follow the uh the
waves of culture you'll get burned is my
point that's the bigger lesson yeah so
there you go even from this Zoom story
their stock jumped 10 after the layoff
well of course because the investors say
yay you cut expenses but what about all
those people I appreciate the 16 weeks
of salary yeah when the healthcare did
you see Google's layoffs they're perks I
mean when they left I was like these
people could retire today just off of
them but that was still as you know wow
Google just laying people the way they
did it was not ridiculous so a lot of
Leadership Lessons to be learned here be
careful all right let's go to New York
City Miranda is there Miranda how can we
help
Hi how are you we're having a blast
what's going on with you
Lindsay and
um I just started listening to the radio
show here just to kind of keep my
financial Guru helping me get out of
debt
um and I have a little bit of a unique
situation so I have about 47 000 in debt
which is all fertility debt that me and
my husband
um you know happily I'm about five and a
half months pregnant now we accumulated
and some of it is on zero interest
credit cards and some one that is is an
11 fertility loan
but the unique thing is I have when we
when we first began this journey I had
money that was tied up overseas in
Europe and since then I was able to
untie that money up so I have about 151
000 shade wow so right so my husband
said you're crazy pay off your debt and
I feel that I just got that money back
so I'm hesitant to do so
um when I'm listening to Dave he does
the deck snowball list your deaths you
know smallest to largest and you know
kind of work through the death snowball
so I had wanted to work my death
snowball and you know my husband thinks
that's crazy when I have the money
sitting in a bank earning you know 3.3
interest
um we're both professional people here
in New York I would say our household
income is about a hundred and I would
say 66 000 we have a home that we
purchased and um we're currently
renovating it we're cash flowing the
renovation we do have a mortgage because
in the tri-state New York area you
cannot purchase a home without a
mortgage and um our goal is really just
to kind of you know pay down the
fertility debt So based on what I'm
telling you I just wanted to know what
Dave's advice would be based on you know
his his plan what other debt do you have
outside of the medical debt
so Miranda it's just it's fertility debt
and then a mortgage which we have about
like 390 000 left on so Miranda George
is going to tell you what Dave would say
because George says it just like Dave
just just a little bit different but I'm
just really curious very quickly what
is scaring you about using some of that
money you just got sent back over to
because I think this is fear-based I
think you're you're reluctant to let go
of it for some fear-based reason am I
right
yes what are you afraid of I'm I'm
afraid that the baby coming and um I
when I go out on maternity leave I will
not have an income and you know children
are expensive and I'm afraid you know
you were just talking about layoffs and
God forbid my husband loses his job and
you know my income all right well let me
get George in here real quick Miranda
that's what you need to do pay off the
debt today and you'll never look back
you won't regret it you still have six
figures sitting there still kids aren't
a hundred thousand dollars a year
expense so just lay it out in the budget
it'll become a line item and you'll be
just fine you have so much money and
once baby's here and healthy and happy
and you've got the budget figured out
let's throw the rest of the house
outside of a six-month emergency fund
and you'll be sleeping a lot better at
night congrats on the on the baby your
husband needs to hear this because very
few husbands hear this honey you were
right
tell him that today and pay it off thank
you for the call congrats on the little
one this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by George Kimmel the
phone number to jump in is triple eight
eight two five five two two five our
scripture of the day comes from Matthew
5 verse 16 in the same way let your
light shine before others so that they
may see your good works and give glory
to your father who is in heaven our
quote of the day from Kareem
Abdul-Jabbar George even know who that
is absolutely what what tell me about
Kareem one of the greatest basketball
players of all time wow he is growing
folks right here before our very eyes
it's only because I've seen Space Jam
too many times that's true uh the quote
from Kareem I think the good and the
great are only separated by the
willingness to sacrifice
he's a deep thinker played for the great
John Wooden
fantastic stuff hey um
George
um you know prices on everything seem to
be continuing to you know we hear a
little bit about it's slowing down
inflation slowing down but it doesn't
feel like it does it no
um and we're here to help figure it all
out we are getting back on the road
again
this week Building Wealth live coming
back to a city near you Indianapolis
this week Thursday Feb uh February uh
16th That's Thursday night February 16th
Dave Ramsey George Campbell Rachel Cruz
and Jade warshaw and then the following
week February 23rd Dave Ramsey myself
John deloney Jade warshaw and Austin
on April the 24th in Salt Lake City Dave
Rachel Christina and George and then the
final stop May 2nd Anaheim California
Dave myself John deloney and Christina
Ellis tickets start at 49 and it says
here that Indianapolis is almost sold
out
I believe it it feels like you just need
to do one Instagram post George that's
all it takes and and it'll just go all
well here's the thing we do these events
and then the next day after they'll go
when you come into Indianapolis I'm like
we were just there yeah where have you
been it's a big world pay attention
folks all right so to get your seat for
only 49 bucks
uh Ramsey Solutions
dot com slash events
ramsaysolutions.com
events there you go all right New York
City again love going back to the Big
Apple Casey is there Casey how can we
help
okay George uh thanks cam for answering
my call I do 100 agree I agree with that
colt from Terry mobile yeah my question
I'm having a bit of uh anxiety and
making this decision my wife and I are
both career employees in the healthcare
industry
um we live in New York
um high taxes
um a little bit of a toxicity in the
workplace we made about 300K in the last
two years uh we're looking to move down
to Georgia however the pay difference is
huge and significant how much different
can you take almost 100K paycheck for
household
um I'm not sure if it's the right move
or not 100 100 000 pay cut so you'll be
going to 200 000 a year
correct okay and where in Georgia
because I lived in Georgia for 11 years
I'm somewhat familiar what area
it will be in around the Gwinnett County
uh area yeah as a matter of fact that's
the county that I lived in uh Gwinnett
County so doing the same type of work
on the same type of work correct okay
but uh each of you making significantly
less have you looked at the cost of
living there if you looked at homes rent
mortgage
yes those those definitely enjoy your
parents out a bit better than of course
New York so those have not been in fact
they're just looking at salary numbers
that is what it's costing me
so if you adjust everything
um and George I want you to jump in here
you know the cost of living I mean your
expenses are going to go down I would
guess pretty significantly yes
yes all right do you own a home in New
York now
we do and and what would you make if you
sell that house
uh currently or about uh 350 left on the
mortgage will make about 575 if we sold
it that's what the agent is saying it
will possibly sell for we were also
looking at the option of possibly just
writing it
um until at least the first year until
we settled down there I wouldn't
recommend that because that's a headache
for you long distance landlord while
you're trying to settle into Georgia is
going to be a tough tough one man I'd
sell and you need the equity if you're
gonna be yeah I would just sell it and
just park that money rent for a year get
used to the area and then you'll know
where you want to live what uh what size
house what price range are you looking
at in Gwinnett County
uh with four kids we're looking at
roughly a four to five bedroom yeah how
many square feet though
uh something small not big uh less than
three three thousand
yeah
um
I'm gonna look that up George while you
give me yeah I think it's a good move to
put some real numbers on this we have an
incredible cost of living calculator uh
that you can get on our website and I'll
have the team put that in the show notes
as well as the YouTube description but
it will break down exactly how much you
need to make going from New York to the
Atlanta area and you can even adjust the
housing utilities food Transportation
Healthcare lifestyle all of those costs
and it will tell you exactly what you'll
need to live but I'll tell you just
based on the numbers you're sharing with
me you can have a great life in Georgia
making 200 Grand but emotionally it
feels like you're taking a huge step
back because you're losing a hundred
thousand dollars which feels crazy
but remember if you move from Georgia to
New York you'd need to make another
hundred thousand dollars
and so it goes both ways it just hurts
because you're moving backwards on paper
but you're really not all right just
give you one idea here George just to
give you some numbers I love doing this
real time this is just one house this is
a very nice looking house uh four bed
three bath 2783 square feet uh in
Grayson Georgia and I can tell you those
good school systems there
um
oh is that right oh that's crazy that I
Ken nailed it I can't believe I just got
lucky the cost 439 thousand dollars God
bless the South so if he sells his if he
sells his house he makes 575
they pay it off he could put a really
nice down payment on that
um and you can really run those numbers
and see what that looks like you're
going to be in great shape because think
about it your mortgage is going to be
way less your cost of living is going to
be way less everything is going to
shrink down
and so another thing you got to do is
we'll we'll send you every dollar
premium our budgeting tool and start to
lay out these numbers and lay out some
different scenarios and go all right our
income is 200 Grand here's what the
numbers could be here's our limits
here's what we're gonna have to adjust
here's the sacrifices we might have to
make or you might find wow we got more
wiggle room than ever before and we're
going to pay off this house within a few
years
and our incomes are only going to go up
and so I want you to be optimistic about
this move I personally feel great about
it
awesome quick last question is would you
recommend rent for a year then buy or go
ahead and buy Lima down there
well I would if you're going to buy you
better be making at least a trip or two
to the area get to know the areas and
really feel it out otherwise I'm just
going to rent a house for a year it's
going to hurt because you're paying rent
when you have a pile of money but you're
going to move with a lot of peace and
wisdom when you go to buy that house
instead of we bought a house we weren't
really doing our research now we want to
move again yep that's a pain right Casey
I I will tell you when I move from
Gwinnett County a little place called
Suwanee Georgia back up here to work for
Dave in 2014 we rented for two years
and we did it because the first year we
were guaranteed we were going we're
going to just get a lay of the land
figure out where we want to drop our
Roots here in the area well year one got
you know close and we're like we're not
ready to buy financially so we took
another year and it's the best decision
we ever made to rent for two years so
um either way George is right you better
spend a lot of time in Gwinnett County
um all over realtor.com which is what I
just did and you can get a real work
with a real good real estate Pro you can
find that at ramseysolutions.com as well
they're called endorsed local providers
these are real pros that we trust they
sell hundreds of homes a year it's not
your brother-in-law who just got his
license and they'll be able to help you
find the right place they know the area
and help you get a good deal but George
there's just something about 12 months
in a place you're gonna get a real feel
I want to know where my favorite
restaurants are what the grocery stores
are yeah and you don't know that no
matter how many weekends you go down to
visit that's a very very good point and
I love the idea of renting yeah and he's
going to stack that cash and you never
know what the real estate Market's going
to do you just don't know that's true so
what do you what are you hearing about
real estate you got a real estate
reality check it's a little bit dry out
there for the folks because of interest
rates and so I think once we see the FED
bring the interest rates back down even
a touch people will get frenzied again
and get excited and we're going to see
real estate tick back up but as far as
home values the crash ain't coming folks
it's just not happening it's just
cooling down for a little bit yeah all
right that's my hot take so if you're
ready buy is what I'm hearing from
Georgetown that's my advice always don't
time the market when you're ready go for
it I love it good stuff always fun to be
with you my friend thank you sir for a
great hour hey you want to thank James
and the entire team behind the glass for
keeping us on and to you America thank
you for listening this is your show this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
if you like what you heard in this
episode and want to know more about
getting started on the Ramsey Baby Steps
go to ramsesolutions.com and click on
the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation again
that's ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]